نعم في الواقع هنا لابد من الاشاره الى ان
الدور الذي كان يتميز به صالح العاروري
على مستوى العمل المقاوم والعمل السياسي
الذي تقوم به حركه حماس كان موقعا متقدما
وايضا كان يقوم بتنسيق كافه الامور
والعمليات التي تحصل من خلال تواجده في
لبنان وكان على تماس مباشر مع كافه اطقا
المقاومه المتواجدين في لبنان هنا سواء
لناحيه حركه الجهاد الاسلامي من جهه من
خلال العلاقات والتواصل معها او من خلال
اللقاءات المتتاليه التي سبق وجمعته
بالامين العام لحزب الله ومن هنا كان يجد
الحديث عن ان الدور الذي يلعبه صالح
العاروري على مستوى العمل المقاوم هو في
موقع متقدم جدا وبالتالي لائحه احتمال
الاستهداف كان واردا دائما ومن هنا كان
يجري التعامل مع ان صالح العاروري وغيره
من كبار القيادات الفلسطينيه المتواجدين
في لبنان هم على لائحه الاستهداف
الاسرائيلي في محاوله لضرب هذا الامتداد
خارج الاراضي المحتله والذي كان يقوم به
صالح العاروري من خلال شبكه العلاقات
والموقع القيادي المتقدم والذي يجمع ما
بين العمل السياسي والعمل المقاوم المسلح
من
خلال كل المعطيات المتعلقه بهذا العمل
الخاص الذي كان يقوم به والذي كان مفتوحا
على تماس مباشر مع حزب الله وغيره من
فصائل المقاومه وبالتالي اليوم هذا
الاستهداف هو يعني عمليا
بانان عندما تؤكد حماس بان اغتيال صالح
العاروري وايضا اثنين من قاده القسام ونحن
هنا نتحدث عن كتائب القسام التي تنشط في
لبنان وهذا ما تؤكده الان حماس من خلال
بيانها فهذا يعني عمليا بان الاستهداف كان
موجها لصالح العاروري الذي كان يقوم بدور
واضح من خلال كتائب عزز الدين القسام
المتواجده في لبنان والتي نفذت مجموعه
كبيره من العمليات خديجه من السابع من
اكتوبر وعندما انطلقت المواجهات عند الجبه
الجنوبيه للبنان وتحديدا في الثامن من
اكتوبر ومن بعدها تم اطلاق مجموعه كبيره
من الصواريخ عمليات عديده نفذتها كتائب
القسام في لبنان من خلال هذه الصواريخ
التي كانت توجه الى العمق الاسرائيلي
نصره للمقاومين في غزه ولاهل غزه نتيجه
الاستهداف العدوان الاسرائيلي الموجه ضدهم
وبالتالي الان استهداف صالح العاروري
واثنين من قاده القسام هو يدلل على الموقع
المتقدم الذي كان يلعبه العاروري والذي
حوله الى هدف عسكري وهدف بمتياز للاغتيال
من قبل الاحتلال الاسرائيلي